This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Chicago River used to be completely filthy. I mean, it's not great now, but it used to be so much worse. The people of Chicago were doing disgusting things to it. waste, human waste, and also as a stock yard screw up in the city, all of the animal waste was jumped into the river and it was said that the river was so thick with a filth that a chicken could walk across it without getting her feet wet. That's Elizabeth Colbert, author of the new book Under a White Sky. What needs to be also understood is that the Chicago River in its original incarnation it flowed eastward into Lake Michigan which was and still is Chicago's sole source of drinking water. So to fix this problem, the city of Chicago carried out a massive project. They reversed the river and sent the sewage water into the Mississippi. When this enormous construction project was completed, which was one of the most enormous
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。芝加哥河过去完全是一条污秽不堪的河流。我是说，现在它也没好到哪去，但以前要糟糕得多。芝加哥的人民对它做了一些令人作呕的事情：废弃物、人类排泄物，还有作为城市里的屠宰场，所有的动物内脏都被倒进了河里，据说这条河脏得厚重无比，一只鸡走过去甚至都不会弄湿脚。那是伊丽莎白·科尔伯特，新书《在白色的天空下》的作者。还需要理解的是，芝加哥河最初的形态是向东流入密歇根湖的，密歇哥湖过去是、现在仍然是芝加哥唯一的饮用水源。为了解决这个问题，芝加哥市实施了一项庞大的工程。他们逆转了河流的流向，将污水送入了密西西比河。当这项巨大的建设工程完工时——这是当时的时代最宏伟的
concerted products of its era, there was a facetious headline in the New York Times that said something like, water in the Chicago River resembles liquid again. By the way, if you want to know more about how it's even possible to reverse the river, we did a whole story about it. Episode 86, it's a good one. Anyway, the river reversal was a big success. Chicagoans had a reliable supply of clean drinking water. But like many large-scale human interventions, there were unintended consequences. The reversal meant two unconnected drainage systems, the Great Lakes and the Mississippi, were suddenly linked up, and that invasive species could move from one to the other.
协同工程之一，《纽约时报》曾发表过一篇戏谑的头条新闻，大意是说，芝加哥河的水看起来又像液体了。顺便说一句，如果你想了解如何能够逆转河流，我们为此做过一整期节目。第86集，那期很棒。不管怎样，河流逆转取得了巨大的成功。芝加哥人有了可靠的清洁饮用水供应。但就像许多大规模的人类干预一样，这也带来了意料之外的后果。河流逆转意味着两个原本不相连的排水系统——五大湖和密西西比河——突然连通了，外来物种得以从一个系统移动到另一个系统。
Both the gray legs and the Mississippi system became highly invaded water systems, especially the gray legs. The gray legs are like a hundred and eighty known invasive species established in the gray legs. And the species of interest right now, sort of as it was put to me by one engineer where the Army Corps of Engineers is Asian carp. If Asian carp reached the Great Lakes, they get pretty much ruined everything. They would eat all of the endangered mollusks
五大湖和密西西比河系统都成了遭受严重入侵的水系，尤其是五大湖。五大湖大约有180种已知的入侵物种在其中扎根。而现在人们关注的物种，正如美国陆军工兵部队的一位工程师向我解释的那样，是亚洲鲤鱼。如果亚洲鲤鱼到达五大湖，它们基本上会毁掉一切。它们会吃掉所有的濒危软体动物
and even threaten the safety of human beings. One of the species has the very annoying habit from a human perspective of flinging itself One of the species has the very annoying habit from a human perspective of flinging itself out of the water when it's disturbed. And what disturbs it often is a boat, a motor, a sound of a motor. And so you get, you know, man-v fish, you get a lot of injuries.
甚至威胁到人类的安全。其中有一种物种从人类的角度来看有一个非常烦人的习惯，那就是当受到惊扰时会把自己从水中……从人类的角度来看有一个非常烦人的习惯，那就是当受到惊扰时会把自己从水中跃出。而惊扰它们的往往是一艘船、一个马达、或者马达的声音。所以你会遇到，你知道的，人与鱼的对峙，你会遇到很多受伤的情况。
You know, I met people whose eye sockets had been broken by Asian carp. Face with this epidemic of fish jumping out of the water and smacking people in the face, the Army Corps of Engineers were told, you have to fix this. And they came up with a series of plans to stop the carp from migrating up the Chicago River, like zapping the river with UV radiation or putting in a big filtration system or dumping nitrogen in the water to basically poison the fish. But what they eventually arrived at was the idea of setting up an electric barrier in the water. This underwater sort of you-shaped structure that has these nodes in it that just causes a lot of voltage through there. So just a recap, we dumped sewage into a river, then reversed its flow by connecting it to an entirely different river, and finally we electrocuted the river.
你知道的，我遇到过眼窝被亚洲鲤鱼撞碎的人。面对这种鱼类跃出水面并扇人耳光的流行病，美国陆军工兵部队被告知：你们必须解决这个问题。他们提出了各种计划来阻止鲤鱼沿芝加哥河向上游迁移，比如用紫外线辐射刺激河流、安装大型过滤系统，或者向水中倾倒氮气来毒死鱼类。但他们最终想到的主意是在水中设置一道电子屏障。这种水下的类似U型的结构，里面有一些节点，会在那里产生高压电流。所以总结一下，我们把污水倒进河里，然后通过把它连接到一条完全不同的河流来逆转它的流向，最后我们电击了这条河。
This is something humans do a lot. We metal with nature, and years later we discover that that creates a whole bunch of unintended consequences, and then we have to metal with nature all over again. These kinds of interventions are the subject of Elizabeth Cobert's new book. Today we're going to talk with Cobert about all the extreme links humans will go to try to undo our mistakes. There are so many examples of situations where people intervene to undo the consequences of previous interventions, but one that really caught me in your book is the introduction of cane toads in Australia.
这是人类经常做的事情。我们干预自然，多年后我们发现这产生了一堆意料之外的后果，然后我们又不得不再次干预自然。这类干预措施正是伊丽莎白·科尔伯特新书的主题。今天我们将与科尔伯特探讨人类为了试图撤销我们的错误而采取的各种极端手段。有太多这样的例子：人们进行干预是为了消除先前干预带来的后果，但在你的书中真正吸引我的是在澳大利亚引入甘蔗蟾蜍。
So let's start right there. How did cane toads get to Australia? So cane toads are native to South America and Central America and the very southernmost tip of Texas actually. They were introduced all around the world interestingly enough into the Caribbean, into Hawaii, and into Australia under the theory, and I don't know where this theory came from,
所以让我们从这里开始。甘蔗蟾蜍是如何到达澳大利亚的？所以甘蔗蟾蜍原产于南美洲、中美洲以及实际上德克萨斯州的最南端。有趣的是，它们被引入了世界各地，引入了加勒比地区、夏威夷和澳大利亚，其理论基础是——我不知道这个理论是从哪里来的——
that they were going to eat the beetles or the beetle grubs that plague sugarcane crops. And so they were introduced into a lot of sugar-producing areas. And they were introduced into Australia in the 1930s in the hope that they were going to do something about these pests in Northeastern Australia, which is a big sugarcane growing region. Now, I think right now, the consensus would be they did nothing. They did absolutely nothing for the sugar cane, but they were like the Asian carb highly successful invaders. They have, you know, basically no natural predators.
它们将吃掉危害甘蔗作物的甲虫或甲虫幼虫。因此，它们被引入了许多产糖区。它们在20世纪30年代被引入澳大利亚，希望它们能解决澳大利亚东北部（这是一个主要的甘蔗种植区）的这些害虫问题。现在，我想大家的共识是它们什么也没做。它们对甘蔗绝对没有任何作用，但它们就像亚洲鲤鱼一样是极其成功的入侵者。你知道的，它们基本上没有天敌。
They're highly toxic. So anything that does try to eat them drops dead very quickly, which has been a huge problem for Australia's native wildlife. But they continue to expand around Australia in coastal regions or a ring around Australia. They can't survive very well in the center of Australia, which is simply too arid, but they're very good at exploiting any source of water. And I myself saw this when I went looking for them one night and wherever there was a little puddle from an air conditioner or whatever there were cantoids. And they're particularly pernicious because they can eat anything. So they're sort of detrimental to the everything below them on the food chain. And there's a toxic. They're detrimental to all the predators because when a predator
它们剧毒无比。所以任何试图吃它们的生物都会很快倒地身亡，这给澳大利亚的本土野生动物带来了巨大的问题。但它们继续在澳大利亚的沿海地区或环绕澳大利亚的环带中扩张。它们无法很好地在澳大利亚中部生存，因为那里实在是太干旱了，但它们非常善于利用任何水源。当我有一天晚上出去寻找它们时，我亲眼看到了这一点：无论哪里有空调或其他东西留下的小水洼，到处都是甘蔗蟾蜍。它们尤其有害，因为它们什么都能吃。所以它们对食物链中它们之下的所有东西都有害。而且它们有毒。它们对所有的捕食者都有害，因为当捕食者
tries to eat them, they kill them. Yeah. And another thing that is important to add here is that a study has no need of turrets. So turrets are just a whole, you know, a class of organisms that did not get to us. I suppose this study has been quite isolated for quite a long time, evolutionarily. You know, there have been interventions, kind of, I don't know, more homegrown style interventions, to deal with cane toads from the beginning. Can you talk about toads busters? Yeah, so toads killing in Australia is a major pastime.
试图吃掉它们时，它们就会杀死捕食者。是的。这里需要补充的另一件事是，这项研究不需要任何群岛。所以群岛只是一类……你知道的，没有到达我们的生物群落。我想这项研究在进化上已经相当孤立很长时间了。你知道的，从一开始就存在一些干预措施，某种程度上可以说是更本土化的干预措施，来应对甘蔗蟾蜍。你能谈谈“捉蟾者”吗？是的，所以在澳大利亚，杀死蟾蜍是一项主要的消遣活动。
People bash toads with golf clubs, they run them over with their lawnmowers, they organize toad-busting malicious to go out and capture toads and put them in the freezer, which eventually kills them, but supposedly painlessly they've come up with sprays. They are constantly looking for ways to reduce their numbers, but when you're talking about, I don't even know if there's an estimate of how many hundreds of millions. It's pretty hard to make a dent in them. As cane toads make their way across the Australian coast, the government is considering more high-tech interventions to stop them. One of those measures is using CRISPR, which is a technique that allows scientists to make small tweaks to DNA. This particular project that I visited at this highly biosecure facility outside of Melbourne,
人们用高尔夫球杆痛击蟾蜍，用割草机碾过它们，他们组织“捉蟾者”民兵出去捕捉蟾蜍并将它们放进冰箱，这最终会杀死它们，但据说是以无痛的方式，他们还发明了喷雾剂。他们不断寻找减少其数量的方法，但当你谈论时——我甚至不知道是否有关于成百上千亿数量的估计。要削减它们的数量实在是太难了。随着甘蔗蟾蜍在澳大利亚海岸蔓延，政府正在考虑采取更高科技的干预措施来阻止它们。其中一项措施是使用CRISPR，这是一种允许科学家对DNA进行微调的技术。我访问的墨尔本郊外这个高度生物安全设施里的这个特定项目，
they were using CRISPR-2 produced hoards that were less toxic. They had disabled the gene that creates an enzyme that makes this toxin so potent. There are two good reasons to make cane toads less toxic. For one thing, they won't kill their predators when they're eaten. But also the predators learn a valuable lesson that cane toads taste bad and will make you sick. This has a lot of potential to mitigate the bad effects of cane toads, but for many people it's a bridge too far. You could potentially disrupt reproduction, so you could potentially have cantoes out there that could not reproduce. And if you manage to spread that trade, then you could potentially make
他们正在使用CRISPR来培育毒性较小的蟾蜍。他们禁用了产生一种使这种毒素如此强效的酶的基因。让甘蔗蟾蜍毒性降低有两个充分的理由。一方面，当它们被吃掉时，它们不会杀死捕食者。但同时，捕食者也会吸取一个宝贵的教训，即甘蔗蟾蜍味道不好且会让你生病。这具有很大潜力来减轻甘蔗蟾蜍带来的不良影响，但对许多人来说，这有些过头了。你可能会破坏它们的繁殖，所以你可能会培育出无法繁殖的甘蔗蟾蜍。如果你成功传播了这一特征，那么你就有可能
a big dent in the cantoe population. But there's a lot of steps along the way and evolution being what it is, the question of whether you could do that is unclear. So the difference between toad busting or even electrifying carp in a river and using CRISPR, it feels different. It might not be different. How does it feel to you? Do those things feel different to you? Well, I think that there is this interesting continuum and somewhat slippery slope.
大幅减少甘蔗蟾蜍的人口数量。但在这个过程中有很多步骤，而且进化就是这样，你是否能做到这一点还是个未知数。所以，捉蟾蜍甚至用电击河里的鲤鱼与使用CRISPR之间的区别，感觉是不同的。它可能并非不同。你觉得呢？你觉得这些事情对你来说有什么不同吗？嗯，我认为这里存在一个有趣的连续体和一个多少有点滑坡的趋势。
And I think that people will look at one intervention and say, oh, yeah, that made sense. And the next one, oh, that made sense. And then you one intervention and say, oh, yeah, you know, that made sense. And the next one, oh, that made sense, you know, and then you kind of go along and go, maybe I'm not so cool about that with that, you know, but I don't subscribe to the notion that there's clearly interventions on one side and clearly interventions on another. They are brayscale, I guess, basically. And
我认为人们会看到一项干预措施说：“哦，是的，那说得通。”然后是下一项，“哦，那说得通。”然后你……你会看到一项干预措施说：“哦，是的，你知道，那说得通。”然后是下一项，“哦，那说得通，你知道，”然后你一路走下去说：“也许我对那个……对那个没那么赞同，你知道，”但我并不认同那种认为显然有些干预措施在一边而另我想它们基本上是一个灰度等级。而且
where one draws the line is a very individual choice. But I think one of the points of the book is also to try to challenge a little bit, or maybe more than a lot, you know, where people do draw a line because gene editing is a technique, for example, that a lot of people find anathema, you know, just shouldn't do it. Now, to be frank, we already do do it a lot, a lot, a lot. Every, I guarantee you, you know, you ate some genetically modified organism in the last few days, you know. It's gene-edited corn, gene-edited soy, as ubiquitous in the U.S. But still people might say, well, you know, I don't want to, I don't
在哪里划清界限是一个非常个人的选择。但我认为这本书的观点之一也是试图挑战一下，或者说不仅仅是一点点，你知道，人们在哪里划清界限，因为基因编辑是一项技术，例如，许多人觉得这是十恶不赦的，你知道，就是不应该这样做。现在，坦白说，我们其实已经在这样做了，很多很多。我向你保证，你知道的，你在过去几天里吃过一些转基因生物，你知道的。它是基因编辑玉米，基因编辑大豆，在美国无处不在。但人们可能仍然会说，“嗯，你知道，我不希望……”
want anything out on the landscape. Certain organisms may not be on the landscape. And I use the example of the American chestnut, which was devastated, destroyed, basically driven to the very edge of extinction by chestnut blight. Now scientists in Syracuse, New York have developed a blight-resistant chestnut that's a transgenic tree, and the choice is sort of between this tree that has one little gene, twEEK, that allows it to be resistant to chestnut blight or no chestnuts. And that's a tough choice in my view. We've been genetically modifying plants for 10,000 years. I mean, look, you've probably eaten
不希望任何东西出现在自然环境中。某些生物可能不应该出现在自然环境中。我举了美洲栗的例子，它被栗疫病摧毁、消灭，基本上被逼到了灭绝的边缘。现在纽约州锡拉丘兹的科学家们培育出了一种抗栗疫病的栗子，这是一棵转基因树，而选择似乎是在这棵只有一个小基因调整、使其能够抵抗栗疫病的树与没有栗子之间做出选择。在我看来，这是一个艰难的选择。我们对植物进行基因改造已经有1万年了。我是说，你看，你可能吃过
a transgender corn, but you've also eaten regular corn, which is the result of agriculture, which is maybe the biggest human intervention that there is. This line between what is a natural intervention versus what is an unnatural intervention is really curious to me. What do you think about that?
转基因玉米，但你也吃过普通玉米，这是农业的结果，农业也许是存在过最大的人类干预。自然干预与非自然干预之间的这条界限对我来说真的很好奇。你对此有什么看法？
Yeah, I mean, I think you're right. It gets very much to this point that there's a continuum, right? I don't think there are too many people around in 2021 who say, you know, plant breeding, that really shouldn't be screwing around with that. You know, that's just too, that's just, you know, bridge too far. You know, it gets to that idea that what you're used to, you're used to acres and acres and whole states worth of corn. And as you say corn itself is a product of many, many hundreds or thousands of years of very careful breeding. But well, it's there. It's always been there. Okay, I'm not appalled by that. Then some people are, you know, appalled by GMO corn, although, as I say, it's almost impossible to avoid in an American diet. My goal is not
是的，我的意思是，我觉得你是对的。这非常符合这样一种观点，即存在一个连续体，对吧？我不认为在2021年还有太多人会说，“你知道，植物育种，真的不应该去搞那个。”你知道，“那太……那只是，你知道，有些过头了。”你知道，这就牵涉到这样一种观点：你习惯了什么，你习惯了成亩成亩、整个州的玉米。正如你所说，玉米本身就是数百年或数千年非常仔细的育种的产物。但是，好吧，它就在那里。它一直都在那里。好吧，我对那个并不感到震惊。然后有些人，你知道，对转基因玉米感到震惊，尽管正如我所说，在美国饮食中几乎是不可能避开的。我的目标不是
to convince anyone not to be appalled. But my goal is to challenge, you know, why are we appalled? Is it simply what we're used to? There are big trade-offs that are being made to large extent unwittingly. And when you bring them to the level of consciousness, the questions become pretty complicated. As we go up the scale of human interventions, climate change is pretty much the biggest way people have messed with nature. And it's becoming clear that just reducing our CO2 emissions won't be enough to stop global warming, even if we get to net zero.
说服任何人不要感到震惊。但我的目标是挑战，你知道，为什么我们会感到震惊？这仅仅是因为我们习惯了吗？在很大程度上，人们在不知不觉中做出了巨大的权衡。当你把这些问题提升到意识层面时，问题就变得相当复杂了。随着我们在人类干预的规模上不断升级，气候变化可以说是人类搞砸自然的最大方式。而且越来越明显的是，仅仅减少二氧化碳排放量还不足以阻止全球变暖，即使我们实现了净零排放。
So scientists are talking about a series of interventions called geoengineering, and they are pretty controversial since they involve messing with the chemistry of the atmosphere. One of these technologies is called carbon capture and storage. I mean, when you hear all this talk now of going net zero in carbon emissions, what's the net? Well, the net is, you know, you're still going to have
因此，科学家们正在讨论一系列被称为地球工程的干预措施，它们相当具争议性，因为它们涉及搞乱大气的化学成分。其中一项技术被称为碳捕获与储存。我的意思是，当你现在听到关于实现碳排放净零的所有讨论时，这个“净”是什么？好吧，“净”就是，你知道，你仍然会有
certain amount of emissions and you're going to have to counter that, balance that with negative emissions. So negative emissions are just sucking CO2 out of the atmosphere somehow. We can talk about how, if you'd like, and storing it somehow. You actually spend a lot of money on a carbon capture system where you pay to a company to offset your emissions in Europe. What happened there? So I, yes, I still spend money. I pay a Swiss based company every month, some of money and the idea is that they,
一定数量的排放，你必须用负排放来对抗、平衡它。因此，负排放就是以某种方式将二氧化碳从大气中抽吸出来。如果你愿意的话，我们可以讨论一下如何做到这一点，并以某种方式储存它。你实际上花了很多钱在一个碳捕获系统上，你付钱给一家公司来抵消你在欧洲的排放。那里发生了什么？所以，是的，我仍然在花钱。我每个月向一家总部位于瑞士的公司支付一笔钱，其想法是他们
actually, they're this machine reason Iceland, they suck some CO2 emissions out of the air, they're, you know, attributed to meme, they suck out some CO2, unfortunately it's only a small fraction of my actual emissions, and they do that in this machine that looks like kind of a giant air conditioner. like kind of a giant air conditioner, then they pipe the CO2 very deep underground in Iceland where all the rock is volcanic rock and you know under heat and pressure and with a lot of water actually there's a chemical reaction where the CO2 reacts with the rock and forms calcium carbonate. So it's locked up there underground, presumably permanently. So that is one form of carbon dioxide removal. And so what are the pros and cons of this?
实际上，他们在冰岛有这样一台机器，他们从空气中吸取一些二氧化碳排放，这些排放被认为是我产生的，他们吸取了一些二氧化碳，不幸的是这只是我实际排放量的一小部分，他们在一台看起来有点像巨型空调的机器里这样做。有点像一台巨型空调，然后他们通过管道将二氧化碳输送到冰岛地下很深的地方，那里的岩石都是火山岩，你知道，在热量和压力下，实际上还有大量的水，会发生化学反应，二氧化碳与岩石反应形成碳酸钙。所以它被锁在地下，据推测是永久性的。这就是二氧化碳去除的一种形式。那么这其中的利弊是什么呢？
I mean, it doesn't really solve the problem. What do you think of it? Well, the pros is your tang, you know, you're tangy or too out of the air and you're locking it up. So that is the obvious pro. The cons are the question of practicality at scale. How's that? I mean, the whole project that I visited in Iceland
我的意思是，它并没有真正解决问题。你对此怎么看？嗯，好处是你在把二氧化碳从空气中抽出来并把它锁起来。所以这是显而易见的好处。坏处是规模化实用性的问题。怎么说呢？我的意思是，我在冰岛参观的整个项目
and they're scaling it up, it's supposed to be able to deal with 4,000 tons of CO2 a year, which might sound like a lot, but is ridiculously trivial compared to the 40 billion tons of CO2 that humans pour into the atmosphere by burning fossil fuels every year. So when you think about that and it takes energy to get my CO2 out of the atmosphere and Iceland, one of the reasons this project is located
他们正在扩大规模，预计每年能够处理4000吨二氧化碳，这听起来可能很多，但与人类每年通过燃烧化石燃料排放到大气中的400亿吨二氧化碳相比，简直是微不足道。所以当你考虑到这一点时，把我的二氧化碳从冰岛的大气中抽出来是需要消耗能量的，这个项目之所以设在
in Iceland for all sorts of reasons, it's located actually at a geothermal plant, which is making producing electricity using the geothermal energy from the center of the earth. But if you imagine doing this at huge scale, how are you getting that energy? And then where are you putting this stuff? There's room in the salt of Iceland for a lot of CO2, but not for all of our CO2. So you have to locate these facilities in various places.
冰岛，原因有很多，它实际上位于一个地热发电厂，该发电厂利用来自地心的地热能来发电。但如果你想象一下大规模地这样做，你是如何获得这些能量的呢？然后你把这些东西放在哪里？冰岛的玄武岩里有容纳大量二氧化碳的空间，但装不下我们所有的二氧化碳。所以你必须把这些设施设在不同的地方。
You'd have to potentially start piping the CO2 around. I mean, carbon dioxide removal using technology has to be when you think about it to make a difference on the scale of the energy infrastructure we have now, and that's just huge. I don't know if you want to call them downsides, but those are the obvious very evident obstacles. Another large scale intervention like this that you wrote about is solar geoengineering. And that's interventions that basically reflect the sun's rays back into space that would
你可能需要开始通过管道输送二氧化碳。我的意思是，当考虑到要对我们现有的能源基础设施规模产生影响时，利用技术的二氧化碳去除必须是——这简直太巨大了。我不知道你是否想称它们为缺点，但这些是显而易见的、非常明显的障碍。你写的另一个这样的大规模干预措施是太阳能地球工程。这就是那些基本上将太阳光反射回太空的干预措施，理论上这可以
in theory cool the temperature of the earth. And the idea is that we slow down global warming this way. Obviously, it's experimental, it's untested. How would it work? There are all sorts of intermediate technologies here too, so there's a technology referred to sometimes as marine cloud brightening where we would manipulate clouds to make them wider. So they'd reflect more sunlight back to space that in theory is possible and in theory could have a sort of regional cooling effect. But the biggie, the big one that the book sort of builds to is this idea that you could spray some kind of reflective substance particles into the stratosphere, these would bounce on my back to space before it hit the Earth.
冷却地球的温度。其想法是我们可以通过这种方式减缓全球变暖。显然，这是实验性的，未经测试的。它是如何运作的呢？这里也有各种各样的中间技术，有时有一种被称为海洋云层增白的技术，我们将操纵云层使其变得更白。这样它们就能把更多的阳光反射回太空，理论上这是可能的，并且理论上可以产生一种区域性的冷却效果。但重头戏——这本书最终引出的重头戏——是这样一种想法：你可以将某种反射性物质颗粒喷洒到平流层中，在这些颗粒到达地球之前，它们会将阳光反射回太空。
So you'd really be getting less direct sunlight on planet Earth, and that would have a cooling effect. Obviously, we haven't tried this on a large scale this humans, but there is a natural analog to this with volcanoes spilling ash into the atmosphere. Yeah. Well, it's not actually the ash that has this impact. It's the sulfur dioxide from volcanoes that gets ejected up into the stratosphere, floats around, forms these tiny little, what are called aerosols, there are sensual little droplets that are highly reflective, why you get such beautiful sunsets after a big eruption. And, you know, people have measured, after Mount Pinatubu in the 90s,
所以地球表面受到的直接阳光确实会减少，这会产生冷却效果。显然，人类还没有在大规模上尝试过这一点，但这在自然界中有火山向大气中喷射火山灰的类似现象。是的。嗯，实际上产生这种影响的不是火山灰。而是火山喷发出的二氧化硫被喷射到平流层中，四处漂浮，形成了这些微小的、被称为气溶胶的微粒，它们是高度反射性的微小液滴，这就是为什么在大规模喷发后你会看到如此美丽的日落。而且，你知道，人们已经测量过，在90年代的皮纳图博火山爆发后，
climate scientists were very interested in this effect, what effect would this have? And they measured it pretty precisely, and it definitely led to a temporary drop in average global temperatures as a result of this effect. And you know, this has been understood for quite a while that volcanoes have this impact. And so the idea behind solar geoengineering is, could we mimic that? And people are also exploring different materials. People have even floated the idea of using diamond dust. You know, there are all sorts of ideas out there. For a long time, environmentalists have seen geoengineering as a total non-starter, because the argument is, it's a long shot if it would work at all, and it's a distraction from
气候科学家对这种效应非常感兴趣：这会产生什么影响？他们对此进行了非常精确的测量，这确实由于这种效应导致了全球平均气温的暂时下降。而且你知道，人们很早就明白火山具有这种影响。因此，太阳能地球工程背后的想法是：我们能否模仿这一点？人们还在探索不同的材料。人们甚至提出了使用钻石粉的想法。你知道，各种各样的想法都有。长期以来，环保主义者一直将地球工程视为绝对行不通的方法，因为他们的论点是，它能否奏效本身就是一个未知数，而且它会分散注意力，让人无法专注于
the real work of reducing carbon emissions. What do you think of that criticism? Well, that's a big concern. This question of if you dangle in front of people some way that we might be able to counteract climate change with that actually reducing our emissions, you know, are you just going to encourage people to, you know, behave badly? And I think that's a big worry. And I think it's a legitimate worry. On the other hand, we are behaving badly. And so the counterargument is, even at the point that we do stop
减少碳排放的真正工作。你如何看待这种批评？嗯，这是一个很大的担忧。如果你在人们面前悬挂某种可能能够抵消气候变化而实际上又不用减少排放的方法，你知道，你是不是只会鼓励人们表现糟糕？我认为这是一个很大的担忧。而且我认为这是一个合理的担忧。另一方面，我们的确表现得很糟糕。所以反驳的论点是，即使在我们停止
emitting CO2, we haven't gotten back the climate of the past. We've simply stopped putting more heating into the system. It'll take probably a few to several decades on some level, century scale, to really reach a new equilibrium. But you're going to continue to melt the ice caps. You're going to continue to see see low rise, the oceans are going to continue to warm.
排放二氧化碳的那一刻，我们也无法恢复过去的气候。我们只是停止向系统中注入更多热量。要真正达到一个新的平衡，在某种程度上——世纪尺度上，可能需要几十年到几个世纪的时间。但你将继续融化冰盖。你将继续看到海平面上升，海洋将继续变暖。
So the counter argument is, well, you may find yourself in such a terrible situation that you're going to want some way of counteracting some of that warming because the alternatives are so awful. And I think that both of those are very legitimate arguments. Yeah. The other part of this, that's interesting, is the word geo. I mean, it is a global thing. And when you're talking about cantoes in Australia, it's at least limited to Australia. Who gets to decide who pours stuff into the stratosphere? It's very difficult to think through because, you know, we're not very good at global
所以反驳的论点是，好吧，你可能会发现自己处于如此糟糕的境地，以至于你会希望有一种方法来抵消部分变暖，因为替代方案实在是太可怕了。我认为这两者都是非常合法的论点。是的。这其中另一个有趣的部分是“地球”这个词。我的意思是，这是一个全球性的事情。当你在澳大利亚谈论甘蔗蟾蜍时，它至少局限于澳大利亚。谁来决定谁把东西倾倒进平流层？这很难思考，因为，你知道的，我们不太擅长全球
governments, you know, witness what's happened with climate change, and people have pointed out that a potentially frightening thing about geoengineering is it could be done in theory by one country or even once again, in theory by one very, very rich person. I don't, personally, once again, this is one woman's opinion. I don't, you know, personally, once again, this is, you know, one woman's opinion. I don't find that a very compelling argument because this is not something you do in secret. This is something that you are flying lots and lots of flights in the stratosphere. We certainly know how to shoot down planes from the stratosphere if we don't want them there.
治理，你知道，看看气候变化发生的事情就知道了，人们指出，关于地球工程的一个潜在可怕的事情是，理论上它可以由一个国家甚至再次理论上由一个非常非常富有的人来完成。我个人——再次强调，这是一个女人的观点——我并不——你知道，个人而言，再次强调，这是，你知道，一个女人的观点。我并不认为那是一个非常有说服力的论点，因为这不是你可以偷偷摸摸做的事情。这是你在平流层中飞行大量航班的事情。如果我们不希望飞机在那里，我们当然知道如何把平流层中的飞机击落。
And so, you know, I think that a bunch of very powerful nations could do it collectively, but I don't think one country is going to be able to sort of go road here. But the question of how you decide and who gets to decide, I don't have a good answer for that. I don't think anyone has a good answer for that. The obvious body, I guess would be the UN know, what have we really been able to agree on as a world since the UN was founded on some of them? The UN is only as powerful as we say it is, is the thing.
所以，你知道，我认为一群非常强大的国家可以共同做到这一点，但我认为一个国家不会独自采取这种越轨行为。但如何决定以及谁来决定这个问题，我没有好答案。我想没有人有好答案。显而易见的机构，我想应该是联合国，你知道，自从联合国成立以来，我们在世界上真正能够就什么事情达成过一致吗？联合国只有在我们说它有多大权力时它才有权力，就是这样。
So there are a lot of risks and reasons to not do this kind of thing. But there's an argument that to mitigate the impact of climate change, we need some form of geoengineering because we've already just emitted so much carbon. Did your opinion on geoengineering change at all when you were writing this book? I certainly think that the book expresses a lot of trepidation about even, you know, that we'd even be considering this. I think I described it in one interview as a sort of respectful horror. But I did find the arguments of people working on it who
所以存在很多风险和不这样做的理由。但有一种观点认为，为了减轻气候变化的影响，我们需要某种形式的地球工程，因为我们已经排放了太多的碳。在写这本书的过程中，你对地球工程的看法有没有发生改变？我当然认为这本书表达了许多担忧，甚至，你知道，我们竟然会考虑这一点。我在一次采访中将其描述为一种“恭敬的恐惧”。但我确实发现从事这项工作的科学家们的论点——他们是非常非常聪明的科学家，你知道，真的非常聪明，而且对大气科学的浸润绝对比我深得多。现在有很多关于修复气候或逆转气候变化的讨论。这是不可能的。这里唯一的可能性就是二氧化碳去除。那仍然非常缓慢。那不会很快产生影响。我们在迅速应对气候变化方面没有多少武器。我发现那场对话比我预期的要更令人担忧，我想。
were very, very smart scientists, you know, really, really smart and a lot more immersed in the science of the atmosphere than I am certainly. The argument that there's a lot of talk now about fixing the climate or reversing climate change. That's not possible. The only possibility here is carbon dioxide removal. That's still very slow. That's not going to have an impact fast. We don't have a lot of weapons in our quiver for doing anything about climate change fast. I found that conversation to be more fraught, I suppose, than I expected going in.
这并不意味着我完全改变了我的看法，但我必须说，确实可以提出一些很有说服力的论点。休息之后，将有更多关于伊丽莎白·科尔伯特的访谈。当你想到我们的干预措施和反干预措施时，很容易将所有这些干预措施视为彻头彻尾的灾难。但这有点像选择性偏差，因为有很多人非常喜欢干预措施，比如狗狗，因为狗狗之所以存在，完全是因为人类干预并驯化了狼。绝对是的，我把这番话——正是你所说的——对大卫·基思说了，他真的是主要的科学家之一，可能比地球上任何人都花更多时间思考地球工程，他是哈佛大学应用物理学教授，我想。
That doesn't mean that I exactly change my view on it, but I have to say that some compelling arguments can be made. After the break, more with Elizabeth Colmer. When you think about our interventions and the counter interventions, it's pretty easy to consider all of those interventions as unmitigated disasters. But it's kind of a selection bias because there are lots of interventions that people like an awful lot, like dockies, for example, because dogs only exist, because humans intervened and domesticated wolves. Absolutely, and I put that exactly what you're saying to David Keith, who's really one of the chief scientists, probably spent more time thinking about geoengineering than anyone else on Earth, a professor of, I think, applied physics at Harvard.
他说，是的，你表现出了偏见，你知道，要计算这些干预措施中有多少我们认为好或坏，这是不可能的，正如你所说，从农业开始，你知道，驯化玉米、小麦和大米，那是一个糟糕的选择吗。有些人会说是的，贾雷德·戴蒙德曾称农业为“人类历史上最糟糕的错误”。但我们就在这里。而且已经无法回头了。我们不会废除农业。那是千真万确的。我们可以对过去一万年甚至更长时间里做出的许多选择感到遗憾，
And he said, yes, you're showing your bias is, you know, it's impossible to do that calculation of how many of these interventions, you know, we would consider good or bad, you know, starting with agriculture, as you say, you know, domesticating corn and wheat and rice was that was that a bad choice. Some people would say, yes, Jared Diamond has called agriculture, you know, the worst mistake in human history. But here we are. And there's no going back from that. We're not getting rid of agriculture. That's for damn sure. We can regret a lot of choices that have made over the last 10,000 years or longer even,
但当星球上有近80亿人口时，我们现在无法回心转意了。那真的不是一个选项。我觉得在心理学上有一些非常迷人的地方，特别是在你谈到新奥尔良的时候。所以，新奥尔良这个地方，从各方面来看，至少从水文学的角度来说，是不应该存在的。从一开始的斗争到现在，它仍然是一场斗争，既要保持足够干燥以便居住，又要出人意料地保持
but we can't turn around now with almost 8 billion people on the planet. That's just not really an option. Something about the psychology that I found really fascinating is particularly when you're talking about New Orleans. So, New Orleans is a place, but by all accounts, at least in terms of hydrology, shouldn't exist. A struggle from the beginning remains a struggle, both to keep it dry enough to live on and surprisingly keeping it
足够湿润以便成为一个港口，这对我来说是新信息。但很明显，为了让新奥尔良继续存在下去，我们将永远把干预措施堆叠在干预措施之上。这就是我们本来的样子吗？嗯，我认为新奥尔良是这种现象的一个极好的例子。它处于密西西比河注入海湾的完美地理位置，当法国人在1718年战略性地决定在此定居时，它还是一片沼泽。而且，你知道，在此之前，人们已经在该地区生活过了。美洲原住民在密西西比三角洲生活了数千年，但他们并没有坚持留在一个
wet enough to be a port, which was new information to me. But it's clear that we will always pile intervention upon intervention to keep New Orleans going. Is this just who we are? Well, I think that New Orleans is a great example of this phenomenon. It's at a perfect location where the Mississippi hits the Gulf, it was a swamp when the French strategically decided to settle in 1718. And, you know, prior to that, people had lived in the area. Native Americans had been living in the Mississippi Delta for thousands of years, but they didn't insist on staying in a place
在洪水季节会被淹没的地方。一旦你开始成为一个建造城市并拥有庞大基础设施的定居物种，你就对这些基础设施进行了投资。而这正是新奥尔良目前正在发生的事情，越来越多的巨型干预措施。我是说，仅仅是，你知道，甚至只是卡特里娜飓风之后建造的东西，都只是庞大无比的水利工程。这是一个非常引人注目的例子，而且由于三角洲正在下沉以及海平面正在上升的性质，新奥尔良的处境极其不稳定。因此，相对海平面是一个巨大的问题。话虽如此，世界上每一个主要沿海城市都将上演某种版本的这种情况。
that was going to get flooded during flood season. Once you start being a sedentary species that builds cities and has tremendous infrastructure, you're invested in that infrastructure. And that was happening in New Orleans right now, more and more humongous interventions. I mean, just, you know, even just what was built after Katrina, just massive, massive water works. It's a very striking example, and New Orleans situation is extremely precarious because of the nature of the delta, which is sinking, and sea level, which is rising. So relative sea level is a tremendous problem. But that being said, every major coastal city in the world is going to be playing out some version of this.
我们将在多大程度上愿意搬迁？我们又将在多大程度上试图从那些日益受到海平面上升威胁的地方榨取每一个可能的十年。我们已经锁定了相当大的海平面上升。没有人能准确告诉你具体是多少。我们继续排放二氧化碳的时间越长，海平面上升就会越多。这是一种非常清晰的关系。这是一种非常清晰的关系。但是，你知道，顺着这份名单看下去。在本世纪的剩余时间里，每一个沿海城市都将与此进行搏斗。
To what extent are we going to be willing to move? And to what extent are we going to try to eat out every possible decade from places that are going to be threatened, increasingly threatened by sea level rise. We have already locked in substantial sea level rise. No one can tell you exactly how much. The more, longer we continue to knit CO2, the more sea level rise we're getting. That's just a very clear relationship. That's just a very clear relationship. But, you know, just go through the list. Every coastal city is going to be grappling with this over the next, the rest of the century.
如果我们因为自己的生活方式和优先事项而永远锁定在一个干预循环中，我们变得更精确了吗？我们变得……我们学到了什么吗？是的，我认为我们变得更有知识了，你知道的。优先事项。我们变得更精确了吗？我们变得……我们学到了什么吗？是的，我认为我们变得更有知识了。比如我确实认为，如果有人决定在三角洲土壤上建造一座新城市，会有人举手说：“等一下，这是一个问题。”但这引发了许多新问题。
If we're locked into, like, an intervention cycle forever because of our lifestyle choices and our priorities, have we gotten more precise? Have we gotten, have we learned something? Yes, I think we've gotten a lot more knowledgeable, you know. priorities. Have we gotten more precise? Have we gotten, have we learned something? Yes, I think we've gotten a lot more knowledgeable. I do think, for example, if someone decided to build a new city on Deltaic soils, someone would raise their hand and say, wait a sec, this is a problem. But that raises a lot of new problems. right? So, you know, there are going to be all these interventions proposed for all these big cities, for example, you know, they're already looking at New York,
对吧？所以，你知道，将会为所有这些大城市提出各种干预措施，例如，你知道，他们已经在研究纽约了，
how are you gonna protect New York? There are lots of massive possibilities. People are going to raise a lot of objections to them as well they should about what they're going to do to, you know, the ecosystem, the New York Harbor, how they're going to just place water from one place to another, et cetera, et cetera. Meanwhile, sea levels are rising, you know. So, I'm not saying that massive interventions are the way to go. It's quite possible that we need to take a lot of smaller steps, which are much more difficult
你将如何保护纽约？有很多巨大的可能性。人们也会对它们提出很多反对意见，就像他们应该对生态系统、纽约港、它们将如何把水从一个地方转移到另一个地方等所做的那样。与此同时，海平面正在上升，你知道。所以，我并不是说大规模干预是唯一的出路。很有可能我们需要采取许多较小的步骤，这些步骤比一个庞大的问题要困难得多
to coordinate than a big massive problem. But those also, even those run into resistance. So we're in a pretty complicated time and situation where a lot of our values are going to come into conflict, both in terms of watching even neighborhoods or cities or never to have a certain self-determining quality, but also not being able to agree on what intervention we need, meanwhile, the water's creeping up. So I don't know how that's gonna play out.
来进行协调。但即使是这些步骤也会遭遇抵抗。所以我们处于一个相当复杂的时代和局势中，我们的许多价值观将发生冲突，既体现在看着社区、城市或永远拥有某种自决品质方面，也体现在无法就我们需要什么干预措施达成一致方面，与此同时，水正在漫上来。所以我不知道这最终会如何发展。
I think it would be fascinating if it weren't so scary. Well, thank you so much for talking with us. Oh, well, thank you so much for talking with us. Oh, well, thank you. Elizabeth Colbert's new book is Under a White Sky, The Nature of the Future. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Chris Baroube, Music and Sound Mix by our Director of Sound Sean Real. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall. Crueck Colesde is the digital director.
如果它不那么可怕的话，我觉得它会很迷人。嗯，非常感谢你与我们交谈。哦，好吧，非常感谢你们与我们交谈。哦，好吧，谢谢。伊丽莎白·科尔伯特的新书是《在白色的天空下：未来的自然》。本周的“99%隐形”由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，音乐和声音混音由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔负责。我们的资深制作人是德兰妮·霍尔。克鲁克·科尔斯德是数字总监。
The resident includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Heavy Madon, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K.L.W. in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the continent, but will always be in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
常驻人员包括埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、海维·马顿、凯蒂·明格、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 K.L.W.的项目，在广播街（Radio Row）制作，广播街散落在大陆各地，但将永远位于美丽的奥克兰市中心，加利福尼亚州。
We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world to find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on, in the show at 99pi org, on Instagram and Reddit too. And you can find out all about our interventions in the world of podcasting at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体，都可以在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，在节目上@99pi org，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到我。你可以在99pi.org上了解我们在播客世界中的所有干预措施。Radio Topia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。